now we all know a messy bun is never as
easy as it looks but this hair hack
might just be what you need to make it
work all you need is a claw clip and two
hair bands put your hair in a ponytail
put your claw clip in like you normally
would but have the Hair Band hanging
from it and flip your hair over the claw
clip now you're going to put your hair
in a bun like you normally would with a
hairband that's hanging from the claw
clip and honestly at this point I really
didn't think it was going to work I was
fighting with this bun to get the hair
band over it however once I doubled it
over it actually created a really pretty
bun just trust the process and stick
with me
there she is it just made it look so
easy I was genuinely shocked I then
pulled out a few strands just to like
mix with the messy bun look but I really
feel like this technique is what you
need for a messy bun what do you guys
think